- Free at last.
Free at last!
Thank God Almighty!
We are free at last!
(southern blues music)
♪ Crazy, crazy ♪
♪ Does is crazy ♪
(suspenseful orchestral music)
(distant owl hooting)
(suspenseful music continues)
(Key gasps)
- Are you Miss Tubman?
- The name's Harriet.
- Well, thank God in Heaven
for the work that you doing, Harriet.
- Before ya thank me,
let me tell ya,
I've led hundreds of slaves to freedom
through this here underground railroad,
but it ain't gonna be easy.
Are you ready?
All right.
Then hike up your britches
and follow me to freedom!
(dramatic orchestral music)
(Harriet yelling and laughing)
(Key groans)
(Key grunts)
Watch this black molasses!
Ha-ha!
Yah!
(Harriet cheers)
(dramatic music continues)
- Ow! (groans)
Well, where is she now?!
(Harriet yelling)
(glass breaking)
- That was the easy part.
Now, stay close!
This next 500 miles gets a little sticky.
(Harriet yipping)
(dramatic music continues)
- Forget this, man, I'm goin' back.
- Free at last.
Free at last!
Thank God Almighty!
We are free at last!
(audience cheering)
- [Announcer] Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome your next speaker,
the Reverend Robert Jones.
(audience applauding)
- How am I supposed to follow that?
I can't, nobody can follow that.
How'm I...
I can't...
Oh.
(microphone feedback)
All right.
Good afternoon, um...
That, that is the best
speech I've ever heard
in my entire life!
Ever!
I have never heard a
better speech! (laughs)
And now it is my turn to speak.
Huh. (laughs)
Who put this running
order together, right?
You know, um, Dr. King,
(laughs) he actually covered a lot,
a lot of what I was gonna say.
Um, you know, my, my speech is, uh,
you're gonna find this funny y'all,
my speech was actually called
"A Vision for the Future."
(laughs) I'm not saying that
Dr. King copied my speech.
(audience uproar)
I'm...
No, no!
No, I'm saying I'm not saying that!
I'm not saying he tried to copy it!
Why don't y'all listen
to what I'm...
(audience uproar)
Wow! You know what?
No, come on!
(audience booing)
I'm just saying! I'm just saying!
I'm just saying, it's a joke!
Did I not say it like a joke?
(audience booing)
Okay!
Nope?
Apparently I have six more minutes.
Let's see, red hills of
Georgia, he got that out there.
Okay...
Okay, you know what?
All right, here, here's
somethin', here's somethin' new.
Here's somethin' brand new.
How about, okay,
this is off, me talking off the top
of my head here, everybody, uh,
how about if we let, uh, black
people enslave white people
(audience booing)
for okay, you know,
that sounded a lot better
in my head before I said it.
(audience booing)
So, that's, uh...
That wouldn't work.
Is it warm?
Is anybody else warm?
Whoo!
Okay, okay, okay, here's what we gonna do,
here's what we gonna do,
all right, Dr. King talked about, um, uh,
all the races coming
together, right, right?
So, what I want every
negro to do here today
is find the nearest white
person and give 'em a hug.
Just, just give 'em a hug, okay?
(audience uproar)
Nope, sir.
You're not being attacked,
you're not being attacked,
you're bein' hugged, okay?
Everybody take it easy, okay?
Everybody relax. You know what?
We don't need 10 negros
hugging one white person, okay?
Let's just, let's, you
know, that's the new rule.
Not ten on one, one on one,
so we'll just take turns
and everything, okay?
So, everybody relax, okay?
Oh my goodness!
Sir, she doesn't need to be defended!
She doesn't need to be
defended! She's okay!
She's okay, okay?
All right, ma'am, okay!
Officer, is that necessary?!
I don't think that's necessary, officer!
No, ma'am! Please!
Please take it easy, sir!
Everybody take it easy, all right?!
These are just hugs,
you're not being attacked!
(water bursting)
Oh, come on! Stop it!
What are you doing?! Oh God!
(audience uproar)
- [Announcer] Ladies and gentlemen,
please turn off your cell
phones and enjoy our production
of "Lunch with Greatness."
(paper fluttering)
- My, my, my!
What a beautiful day
in Montgomery, Alabama,
(audience applause)
I swear the sun is so
hot, I nearly melted.
- Indeed, Dr. King,
(audience applause)
but I suspect we didn't meet
here to talk about the weather.
- Indeed, Brother Malcolm.
Unless, of course,
we articulate
that the sun in this country
shines brighter on some
than it does on others.
- [Audience] Mm-hmm.
- Yes, but when the sun does shine on us,
it is growing the seeds of revolution.
- Mm-hmm.
- Amen.
- That's what I'm talkin' about.
- I see your point, Brother Malcolm,
but do not those same
seeds need to be watered
with love?
- [Audience] Mm-hmm.
- Well, I suppose that is the subject
of some discussion Dr. King.
(paper fluttering)
(audience member coughs)
- And I am all for
discussion Brother Malcolm,
unless, of course, the words devolve
into proclamations of hate!
(audience applauding)
- Well, is that not why we
are here today, Dr. King?
To discuss.
(fly buzzing)
(paper fluttering)
- Yes, Brother Malcolm.
And I am confident that as we discuss-
- Oh, we are going to discuss it
and discuss it
until
I say
that
our people have never resorted to violence
before the white man gave them no choice
but to pay him back in the
only currency he understands!
(audience cheering)
- Brother Malcolm,
is that what you really
have to say at this point
in our lunch?
- Indeed, Dr. King,
because we didn't land on Plymouth Rock,
Plymouth Rock landed on us!
(audience cheering)
- That's the truth!
- Amen!
- Okay, well, yes, all right, yeah,
I've heard you say that before.
I don't know why we're
talking about rocks,
when in fact, it is the flesh
and the bone and the dreams...
I have a dream that someday
our children will be judged
by the content of their character,
not by the color of their skin!
(audience cheering)
- Yep, yep, yep, yep, same for me!
Same for me!
In fact,
I believe that one day a black man
will become the president of
the United States of America!
(audience cheering)
Hopefully for eight years!
(audience cheers)
Obama, 2012.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, of course eight years,
of course eight years!
That's a given, right?
(laughs) That's a given, you know?
I mean, but in order to get there,
isn't he going to need the help
of our strong, beautiful black women?!
(audience cheering)
Gotta respect the sisters!
Gotta respect the sisters.
(audience applause)
- As Wesley Snipes said in "Passenger 57,"
"Always bet on black!"
Yeah!
(audience cheering)
(all cheering)
- West side!
West side!
(cheering continues)
- And that's what we're here to say,
is that we are the new
Black Panther Party.
- [Interviewer] What's the biggest problem
facing the movement?
- Well, you know,
we supposed to be in this era
of so-called post-racial harmony
with all people in America,
but us blacks are being
murdered all over the place
and we get the same treatment
time and time again!
We're not even second class citizens.
We third class!
Stand up, Black America,
and declare to white America
that we aren't gonna take this no more.
Okay?
- [Interviewer] Why come
out now and say this?
- You know what?
You had 400 years to
get it right, America,
but you don't know how
to treat your people,
all people!
It's time to stand up!
It's time to take back!
It's time for us to fight back!
And we won't take your
phony words anymore,
we're not gonna do it.
We want concrete results!
No, you, you, you hear
what we're saying to you?
United snakes of America!
What are you supposed to do
when the whole world is watching
and no one is saying anything?
We will not be silent!
- [Interviewer] Okay, you sir,
anything you wanted to say?
- Oh, me? No, I'm good.
(upbeat beatboxing)
♪ All I want, yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪